Trump is seizing the means of production
he really he really is it's it's great
isn't it the government sees in the
means of production where all the
economies to be celebrating
they've been demanding that Trump
invoked the defense production act for a
long time even the Democrats that's what
I mean yeah the the Democrats that well
of course they are they want the
government to seize the means of
production right so of course they're
happy about it Trump has finally invoked
to the defense production act to force
the 3m corporation to start diverting
its masks to us both from Southeast Asia
and what they produce here to stop
exporting them natural is is causing a
lot of people to get really angry we had
this story from New York Times Trump
seeks to block 3m masks exports and grab
masks from its overseas customers the
move would significantly expand the
American government's reach and reverse
president Trump's hesitant use of the
defense production act this is a wartime
power yeah DPA oh is it was it was in it
was worth like the Korean War I think or
something in the fifties and it was
invoked for a couple weeks now right
yeah almost a month maybe whatever but
apparently but he hasn't used it yet he
has now oh yes right this is it this is
the the first time he's used it yeah so
Trudeau is naturally mad everybody was
opposing masks from US and mad this is a
domino effect yeah we have a shortages
of masks so we were supposed to getting
a bomb we were supposed to be getting
masks from China China turns around the
ship right China is like we need them
more so that everyone in the US is like
we gotta start building stuff in our own
country so we do then a bunch of people
say Trump isn't invoking the defense
production acting he needs to so Trump
then starts you know he will he tells 3m
that the big thing that was missed from
this that while the media don't wanna
really say is that these companies were
already doing it right you had a bunch
of companies that agreed yeah he didn't
need to force him to do anything so he
starts telling all of these companies
you need to you know make us mass and
medical supplies and they just did it
yeah he then got criticized for not you
know forcing him to do it when they
didn't need to yeah but can't you see
like if if he were to just invoke it and
then instantly start doing it they'd be
like Bob he's the authoritarian that we
thought he was the right you know like
of course he's gonna just start abusing
his power absolutely so it's like one or
the other it's like I'm actually kind of
surprised that the way that they
built him up to be such this bad guy
that he didn't abuse the power right
away
like he wasn't he didn't like snap his
fingers like all right I have the power
hold my beer use only here's the bigger
picture from The Guardian us accused of
modern piracy after diversion of masks
meant for Europe will this strain the
relationship between the Europe in the
u.s. whether or not we're gonna see
World War 3 the breakdown of relations
between every single urban centre is
happening okay that's true it's not just
the EU complaining about the u.s. it's
Germany closing its borders to France
and Austria you know it's Rhode Island
ordering the National Guard and the
police to go door-to-door looking for
new yorkers yeah it's Trump saying maybe
we had a quarantine New Jersey
Connecticut in New York so it's a
breakdown of local borders too yeah
everything so in the last segment we
were talking about World War 3 yeah yeah
we got you know China is encroaching on
the South China Sea Venezuela's
attacking this cruise liner it's a
hilarious and pathetic story everybody
makes fun of Venezuela they're pathetic
but now we can see that the the pandemic
might actually be substantially worse
than this it might be like New York City
completely separate from the rest of New
York it's gonna be you know Philadelphia
closes the bridge so those in the south
you know South Jersey suburbs of Philly
are completely cut off from Philly yeah
trapped on the peninsula that's the
crazy thing about all this like Rhode
Island straight up said if you're from
New York we're gonna hunt you down like
we're gonna go door to door and we're
gonna find you yeah so we don't want you
here to what extent you know I don't
know how this will impact relationships
between the US and our allies but where
were we were being strained at home as
well over in Europe they're facing
something very similar this is from CNN
not necessarily a big fan of CNN but
here's the story coronavirus sparks a
war for masks as a key accusations fly
even within France we saw something
crazy
they were alike medical supplies coming
from France to go into the UK and France
impounded the trucks yeah so we're gonna
start fighting each other man like what
happens when Canada's out of masks are
they gonna go in and grab the truck and
be like no way dude we need it they're
gonna come into America and take it is
that what you're suggesting you
they're not gonna do that no no way what
happens when people are desperate
Venezuela just attacked a cruise ship
that's true I think I think you're right
you know it's very very extreme to thing
that could happen I think we did an
Excalibur at be like welcome to the
American Empire now we'll give you stuff
you're right or you know look the US II
first state Canada I guess oh that's
great you're enthusiastic well I like
them too but I mean don't take their
company how many provinces can they have
no they have like 20 yeah it's not I was
less than that gonna be like 75 States
of America it was like seven or
something no no not the huge like big
massive know they got a button once hey
guys I got a much problem I don't know
anything about Canada's government we're
Americans we don't I don't either I
don't they know everything about us
though because they're America jr. so
there's a there's a bunch of different
aspects to this and the reason why I
wanted to highlight Trump's seizing of
masks mm-hmm and I don't mean that in a
negative way I mean he's like taking
them for American use yeah New York
announced recently that illegal
immigrants will get access to the
hospital system how can we
simultaneously complain that our masks
are going to other countries while also
claiming that people who are not
citizens of our country would have
access to our medical system you're
right
didn't you just tell me didn't you just
tell me that dot that in New York City
mm-hmm an emergency alert went out to
all medical students help tell us what
happened so yeah so I was I was gaming
earlier with a few of my friends and one
of them happens to be in New York he's
in Staten Island but that's New York
City and I heard you know the emergency
broadcasts your phone lights up and he's
like Oh what is this and he reads that
he reads it and it's basically saying if
you're a medical student if you're if
you know anything about like being a
nurse being if you're a doctor report to
your nearest hospital where we need you
right now so they're they're literally
sending an alert system on all phones
all broadcasting in the New York area
come and help us they it was there was a
report that medical students were being
graduated early nurses certainly nurses
they were just like congratulations
you're done it's like what I've never
actually don't care go there we'll send
you the diploma in a few years
yeah we're kicking the bird out of the
nest here's your clinicals for yeah so
now fly so so you mean to tell me that
Europe is fighting amongst the own the
countries within their own union over
resources and borders even in the US we
got border disputes between states Trump
had had to dispatch big hospital ships
yeah to LA and New York and New York has
like but don't worry non-citizens will
have access to all of this health care
the first thing I'll point out they
should in the immediate yeah because for
one we want to stop the spread of the
virus and there are people we have to
treat make sure they live but there will
be a reckoning because we cannot come
out of this with people asking that
people can asking the question to me
that sounds like a seeds for the Civil
War right like what yeah why does your
grandma get to live in mine doesn't know
because your grandma's taking her bed
she got sick first
no that's not fair you guys wait your
grandma's not a citizen oh snap
you want to know what's scary though man
you want know it's scary though what
it's really easy for me to say right now
we should definitely treat non citizens
illegal immigrants yeah but what happens
when there's no hospitals left and
there's bodies lining the streets and
there's someone who's not a citizen in
front of the hospital and the doctors
coming out and there's someone who is
with their mom they're gonna be like I
will end you to save my mother's life
and that's when it gets crazy right now
not every hospital is overloaded they're
getting there all I can think of is when
you're coming back into the country
there's a US citizen line and a non-us
citizen line and I see that happening
yeah you know what why wouldn't that be
the case all the American citizens go in
until there's no more then they start
taking in the non Americans yeah it's
it's you know we have we had the open
borders activists for years saying like
we should decriminalize border crossings
doesn't every single Democratic
candidate look like a [ __ ] right now
when they all sit in the debate stage we
will give access to health care we will
decriminalize border crossings we will
put a moratorium on deportations we
don't have enough hospital beds New York
is launching emergency shelters
emergency hospitals they're launching
ships because we don't have the
resources for this and the entire thing
right now is that Trump has to invoke a
wartime measure to seize masks that
we're gonna be given souls to other
countries he instructs 3m to stop give
it exporting out these masks we were
criticizing China for doing the same
thing these countries by the Masters
from us and then Trump steps in no yet
people had the nerve this entire time so
there's gonna be a reckoning you know we
talked about the feminism aspect of all
of this going back to the 1950s
assignment about that
if Rhode Island is enforcing its borders
if Louisiana and Florida are enforcing
their borders yeah you think the United
States as a whole is not gonna enforce
this borders gonna be crazy
you know I was for those some know that
I've been playing Division two and it
goes back to New York so I've been in
running around New York it's really cool
I used to live in New York for six
seventeen years and the final fight is
on Liberty Island which is the Statue of
Liberty and there was a quote on the
wall right when you get in there and I
was like I read it and I was like whoa
like that's and I read it I just pulled
it up here it says give me your tired
your poor your huddled masses yearning
to breathe free the wretched refuse of
your teeming Shore send these the
homeless tempest-tossed to me I lift my
lamp beside the Golden Door and it's
like wow like that is not what I feel
the general environment of America is
right now it used to be so much easier
to say that I know you're right you
Schnauzer now we have 28,000 people per
square mile in New York City
how many hospital beds do they have
thousand how many how many how many
police officers New York City has more
like eight thousand eight thousand eight
thousand and one in six is infected
really yeah Wow
I could be wrong about that Factory I
don't pull that source up I always want
to be careful this I always line up all
my sources whenever I say stuff but I
was watching the news the other day and
that's what I remember seeing I'll tell
you what man if the NYPD gets crippled
someone's gonna be hungry someone's
gonna go to a hospital and they're gonna
be like I'm sick save me please they're
gonna back we can't yeah but it's also
it also goes back to you know how bad
things can really get with the
hospital's doing the talking about the
do not resuscitate orders yeah um I
think we're heading towards it's not
gonna be scapegoating you know people
want to say it's scapegoating of like
minorities or
or you know whatever but you you better
damn well believe that someone's gonna
be with their mom or their daughter wait
till you see some dude who was like 45
he's got you know 13 14 year old
daughter who's sick and coughing up
blood you know and they get to the
hospital and there's someone who's not a
citizen he's gonna be like you know what
I'm gonna be very careful hi phrases but
I'll tell you that that dad would be
like I have no problem going to prison
for the rest of my life to make sure my
daughter lives and right and here's the
thing there's me a lot of Americans are
in a be like I don't blame him those
people weren't supposed to be you know
they came here illegally they broke our
laws they cut the line they displaced
other people you know why are they
getting that and and I'll make it clear
and child they as human beings
non-citizens should receive the
treatment of our son
yeah I'm Mike my fear is that we will
come to a point where where all the
hospitals are overloaded they're already
treating people in hallways we had a
thousand people what died the other day
in a single day dude in New York City
it's gone a little step above the DNR
they paramedics when they find people
who are in cardiac arrest if they cannot
resuscitate on the teeth they cannot
resuscitate on sight they leave them Wow
you're dead
that was jacked up we are gonna see a
reckoning in this country once it is
over where it's gonna be it's gonna be
before the 1950s it's gonna be hardcore
nationalist lock the borders down
manufacturing if you're not a citizen
who are you what are you doing here yep
it's gonna be different
excuse me and let me see your papers
yeah we're already read we're already
doing that are you serious
no I know my friend posted my friend
posted I saw this on social media
holding a badge that says essential
worker yeah you go outside without it
they're like what are you doing I would
have that if I still worked at the
hospital because that's what you get
like you have to be able to demonstrate
that you're I mean that's that's been
the case for I lived in Arizona for a
long time and pretty much anywhere along
the southern border
you'd have to produce I mean even you
know what driving here we got pulled
over
oh and my wife is a Swedish citizen and
she's were married now so she can live
here legally and they she didn't have
her passport and they were like a US are
you US citizens and she couldn't say yes
cuz she's not a citizen
she's she's got a green car right but I
had I didn't have my passport that guy
didn't even ask me anything she just
said oh I I'm not and he was like I saw
the look on his face like whoa all right
and she's like well let me get my
passport and like it was we had our my
car was packed you know so she had to
she had to get out of the car and go
walk around suddenly there was 13 police
officers surrounding my car when it went
to the southwest
driving here when I move moving here
just a couple months ago yeah and I was
just like well like I'm still sitting in
the passenger seat because it was her
turn to drive at that moment so it was
just like you know I'm like okay you
know this is weird but she I knew she
had a green card she got in her backpack
and came back around handed the guy and
he was like okay all right you can go
didn't even ask me I I could have I
could have been legal he didn't even ask
me for anything just the fact that she
said no and I need to go get this
definitely but I think I mean anyone
could have they they probably were
following protocol like if it wasn't
illegal who was going into the back to
get a gun or something you know it's
like they were proud they surrounded our
car though it was very quickly and they
didn't say anything it was like a
unspoken thing like they just all nude
and they just like filtered out and just
were surrounding the car I was like
what's a scary man you know why hmm cuz
I think back to like I know I really
hate making the comparison because
everyone does it you know Godwin's was a
guy ones law yeah World War two mm-hmm
when they were demanding papers there
was no legitimate reason for other than
they were you know anti-semitic they
were racists they were supremacists yeah
if you take all of that ideology but
tacked on an actual pandemic right then
everyone will agree with you and say oh
please check their papers you what
they're doing in China they're making
you get a code to prove you're not sick
right yeah yep yeah I was reading a
story about it that you have to like
check in and if you leave the city then
your code becomes void and they track
you via GPS yeah they're putting ankle
monitors on people yes and Google is
starting to use location source to kind
of track how well people are complying
with quarantine orders yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the
Show Live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you